swearing gets a bad rap for a long time
it was associated
let me try again
swearing gets a bad rap for a long time
it was associate
swearing gets a bad rap for a long time
it was a shoshi
mine is a piece today
for a long time it was associated only
with poor or low class people in fact
the word vulgar originally just meant
common but if you've ever watched
succession you know that today the rich
and powerful dropped plenty of f-bombs
you're not dignifying that question with
an answer you can both
despite their popularity the gatekeepers
of language often like to pretend that
bad words don't exist
dictionaries and etymologies ignored
them for hundreds of years which is why
today it's so hard to tell how they
originated anything that even sounds
like a swear word gets scrubbed from
acceptable vocabulary which is why a
donkey and rooster have replaced their
forerunners even shakespeare had his
cusses removed from some additions zooms
what a tragedy but so-called bad words
are a fundamental part of human
vocabulary and there is some evidence
that using them in moderation may
actually be good for your psyche
i'm dr erica brazovsky and this is outer
words
other words we'll do it
[Music]
live other words
even the cleanest mouths among us have
stepped on a lego or gotten some bad
news and let an expletive slip
linguists call this non-propositional
swearing meaning unplanned almost
involuntary outbursts for a long time
psychologists discouraged this type of
swearing because they thought it
catastrophized negative emotions meaning
it made you feel even worse but then why
would we all have this reflexive urge to
do it oh
this is what psychologist dr richard
stevens wondered and he sought to test
it with a very cool experiment
participants were asked to hold their
hands in buckets of ice water for as
long as they could once while repeating
a swear word and once with the neutral
word
no matter what order they went in
swearing increased the average amount of
time they could withstand the pain by 50
percent
the swearing was acting as some kind of
pain management mechanism subsequent
studies for these findings out and there
was evidence that swearing was affected
at lessening social and emotional pain
as well
in some experiments it seemed that the
naughtier the word was the more
effective it was so saying shoot or gosh
darn was like taking children's tylenol
better than nothing but not as good as
the real deal like medicinal painkillers
they can also be overused people who
tended to swear a lot got less of a
benefit from it to understand what the f
is going on here we'll have to take a
look inside the human brain most people
know that the brain is divided into two
hemispheres the left side which
specializes in higher order reasoning
and the right side which is all about
emotion and creativity in reality it's
quite a bit more complicated than that
but you get the idea most of our
language functions reside in the left
hemisphere which makes sense because
language involves the arrangement of
complex thoughts
swearing however seems to rely more on
the right side of the brain this has
been witnessed by neuroscientists in
real life people have suffered massive
damage to the left side of the brain
often lose significant language ability
a condition known as aphasia
however many of them retain their
ability to swear and tend to swear more
often
conversely many who have suffered damage
to the right side of the brain can still
speak clearly and coherently but seem to
lose the ability or urge to swear
swearing at least the non-propositional
kind is clearly more of an emotional
reflex than a rational behavior that's
why some linguists think it's more akin
to a dog's bark or alliance growl than
human language it quickens the heartbeat
dulls pain gets us ready for action
and because it's so associated with
emotion swearing can actually help build
trust studies show that groups that
swear conversationally tend to forge
stronger bonds and perform better at
shared tasks
displays of emotion like swearing are
generally interpreted to be more genuine
and harder to fake than ordinary speech
and breaking taboos in front of other
people implies a level of shared trust
and understanding swearing can even
minimize the potential for violence by
offering an outlet for aggression
instead of throwing punches or pulling
hair we can show how we are with words
instead such displays of aggression as a
substitute for violence are pretty
common throughout the animal world the
words we consider bad give us power
because they are taboo but if you go
back 500 years it was the other way
around
bad words were considered taboo because
people believed they had power
back then naughty language was focused
on god and religion invoking the deity's
name swearing by something sacred or
cursing someone were supposed to have
real effects in the real world
this is why we call them swears oaths
and curses or cusses some of
shakespeare's favorites splod slid zunes
we're shortening of god's blood god's
eyelid and god's wounds
if you're swearing by god's body parts
the next thing you say better be true or
your soul may pay for it and you didn't
say damn you or go to hell unless you
really wanted someone to go to hell like
literally
as culture became more secular taboos
shifted from religion to things like sex
excrement and body parts though it's
hardly universal
in germany some of the worst swears
involve animals calling people dogs or
pigs and in japan there's not such a
stigma around feces in fact they seem to
find it kind of cute so having a day
might be a good thing whatever the taboo
is the important thing is that it's
shared we've all collectively agreed to
put certain words behind glass
not so that they're never used but so we
can know when it gets real
it may not be the most sophisticated
form of expression but there's a primal
magic to swearing that's still with us
after thousands of years and like any
magic if you use it too much it can lose
its powder
power
wait before you go i think you're gonna
love fate and fabled a brand new show
here on storied co-hosts dr emily zarka
and dr moya mcteer unpack ancient myths
and legends to find out why such tales
were crafted and investigate mythology's
influence on humanity their first
episode on the fates is live right now
so maybe it's destiny that i'm telling
you about it now be sure to tell them dr
b sent you but then why would we all
have this reflexive urge to do it ow
sort of a pitch so having a jiggy day
might be a good thing
fungi
other words fudge it we'll do it live
but so that we can know when chin gets
real power butterfrogger